[Music]
hey guys so we have been spending a ton
of time at home and I'm sure you guys
have been as well seeing we're currently
in the pandemic so we all have to be
staying at home and what does that mean
when you're at home usually is to stick
your face in front of a whole bunch of
different screens like you know spending
a lot of time on your phone or on your
on your laptop or you know like watching
movies or you know just been watching
things or playing video games like this
kids been doing constantly he has
literally been plugged in this entire
time and as parents are just kind of
getting a little concerned especially
for his eyesight cuz you know like
spending a lot of time in front of a
screen can't be good for your eyes
they're really excited to announce that
we are partnering with global myopia
awareness coalition for this video and
in case you don't know what myopia meant
it actually means nearsightedness for
example me in Casey and Isaac we have
this issue where we are able to see
objects clearly up close but once we
move further away from the object it
kind of gets a little blurry so in order
to help spread awareness about myopia we
are partnering with global myopia
awareness Coalition game on battling
myopia in real life campaign exactly so
what that means is we are gonna be
taking one of Isaac's favorite games
it's called hallo neighbor we're gonna
bring that video game into real life and
so the whole concept behind this game is
where there's this kid that's trying to
sneak into his neighbor's house to find
out the neighbors secret dark secret
dark secrets but in this scary game yeah
it's kind of like a jump scary game kind
of thing it's like kinda hide-and-seek
so in this game we will be taking
I'm gonna be changing the Wi-Fi password
and we have the new password right here
so the way this game is gonna play out
is Isaac it's going to be sneaking in
from the front door and somewhere in
this downstairs area he needs to find
these keys that we're gonna be hiding
and these keys open up this box which
this box will be hidden
upstairs in units or rooms and as you
can see what's inside this box is
Casey's car keys so cute Isaac then will
be opening up
Casey's trunk to reveal the new Wi-Fi
password and then he could plug in again
but we're really trying to find creative
ways to get this kid down try not to be
honest cream yet so your life can't be
fun really you know cuz we play video
games together all the time but it's
just you know we have to be careful with
our eyes we don't want to worsen our
myopia and then Casey will be playing
the role of the neighbor so he's gonna
be sitting here the neighbor has been
most passionate oh yeah he hasn't much
so he's gonna be sitting here working on
his laptop with headphones on and just
to make it a little bit like more of a
handicap like another handicap is these
glasses so he's gonna have these
sunglasses just cuz we wanted him to
look cool you know so he's gonna be the
neighbor that Isaac has to try to avoid
getting cut are you gonna go turn off
the way yes okay
take your phone text me when you got it
takes me when like the countdown okay I
don't want to see this kid reaction see
if he actually notices he has no more
Wi-Fi
[Music]
you good you good oh well how could that
happen I don't know do you want to earn
your Wi-Fi back yeah
alright come on over here we're gonna be
playing a game we are gonna be playing
hello neighbor
cool in real life I'm the neighbor you
are gonna be looking for these keys okay
okay these keys are going to open this
box and inside this box is daddy's car
keys and inside the car in the trunk you
will find the password or I can take
care of you now no geared up
are you ready to start the game yeah
find those keys in the boy and don't get
cut yes
all right start from the outside all
right
game on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're a
[Music]
David you're good Manny you literally
guess where the the key the actual box
is on the first try show me your new
Wi-Fi password Oh your camera so crooked
okay game over myopia well now I have
the Wi-Fi password why don't just go
boxing never go baby how was that that's
fun yeah so you don't really need
screens off buddy I know yeah I don't
play games just got it
I could go bike-riding we could do more
of these in real life video game you do
hide the cheek of the dark yeah exactly
it's so easy to just get away from
screens
luckily from partnering up with global
myopia awareness coalition we were able
to discover that it is very very
important to keep up with your kids
comprehensive eye exams every year
because most kids they don't even
realize that they have blurry vision
it's also very important as a parent to
just keep up with that and make sure
that your kids eyes are nice and healthy
so all the parents out there schedule an
appointment with your eye doctor asked
about myopia because your baby's eyes
are very important and just like with my
baby we were trying to make sure that he
just gets a nice little screen break
because screens not very good for your
eyes you're all sweaty dude I'm actually
really really really impressed that you
were able to get it quickly it sounds
like maybe if we make it like too hard
it might be too hard but then I was like
not too easy if it'll be too easy
it's too hard
[Music]
but thank you guys for watching this
video and things again to global myopia
Awareness Coalition for partnering with
us in this video Isaac had a great time
and go get your kids eyes checked
[Music]